[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour jimmy
et bonjour à patrice à la glisse à lachy
qui réalise ce matin ce sera notre
caddie dont l'invité et christian
boutant bonjour christian boutant
penchot un meilleurs voeux à vous
meilleurs voeux à tous à tous et c'est
un espace y ont voient la technique est
bien sûr vous êtes très connu en
martinique eux comme ex directeur de la
sacem
puisque vous êtes à la retraite
concernant cette fonction mais vous êtes
membre du csm notamment membre de son
conseil économique
enfin de sa commission culture et
communication excuse moi et excusez moi
et donc le csm c'est le conseil
économique social environnemental de la
culture et de l'éducation de martinique
un conseil consultatif auprès de la ctm
de la collectivité territoriale voilà le
csm et sa commission dont culture et
communication qui a produit qui a rédigé
une motion de soutien aux professionnels
de la culture en martinique il y a
quelques semaines on va en parler mais
avant de parler des perspectives pour
cette année 2021 on va faire un état des
lieux avec vous christian boutant voilà
on va planter le décor est ce que parce
que le csm en fait a exprimé sa
préoccupation et ses plus vives
inquiétudes quant au sort des
professionnels de la culture ici alors
est-ce à dire que la situation a
aujourd'hui à l'heure où on parle elle
est peut-être un peu moins dramatique
qu'il y a quelques semaines mais enfin
c'est une situation qui reste encore
désastreuse et peut-être catastrophique
sur le secteur surtout qu'elle dure
parce que c'est depuis le 16 mars que
nous avons été dans le premier
confinement et depuis les semences les
activités du spectacle delà de la
culture de manière générale des
expositions du théâtre sont arrêtés
alors directement sont concernés tous
les professionnels
et puis ceux qui pratiquent qui ne sont
peut-être pas professionnel mais en tout
cas qu'ils en tirent des revenus mais
sont concernées toutes les filières
aussi le biais d'activités annexes
autour de ddd des spectacles des
concerts
voilà voilà et puis à des techniciens
il y a s'ils voulaient le secteur le
secteur présente du spectacle vivant
c'est un secteur qui active la diffusion
la production les services les
fournisseurs les prestataires donc il y
a effectivement une infinité d'activités
qui sont liées à l'événementiel et qui
activent l'économie 1 c'est bien pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on sait bien que le
secteur de la culture est plus important
quantitativement que celui de
l'automobile
oui alors c'est ça parce que c'est
finalement le secteur culturel a fait
partie de ce secteur dit de d'activité
ou de deux je dirais de métier
d'activité professionnelle non
essentiels concept non mais bon c'est
alors toute la vitalité du secteur
montre son caractère essentiel le
spectacle aujourd'hui la culture sont
des éléments qui sont fondamentaux dans
l'existence humaine est là et dans le
développement
alors effectivement le csm a cru bon
bien évidemment de se mobiliser pour
pouvoir poser les questions pour pouvoir
souligné c'est ce que s'il ya un constat
quand même qui est qui est ce qu'il est
et qui est brutale en fait parce que
vous dites les artistes musiciens
comédiens danseurs créateur visuel
plasticien auteurs techniciens ainsi on
le disait que des professions associées
n'ont plus les moyens de travailler ils
ont des difficultés à créer ou produire
et présenter leurs oeuvres ça veut dire
que c'est l'essentiel le nom même de
leur activité qui est là qui est qui qui
a été attaqué au niveau national au
niveau plus large la culture est
suffisamment aujourd'hui un secteur qui
est identifié comme fondamentalement
atteint alors au delà donc de tous les
autres objectifs bien évidemment c'est
de profiter si je puis dire de cet
environnement de cette situation qui est
inédite pour pouvoir d'une part se poser
des questions d'autre part réfléchir à
la mise en place de dispositifs
structurants durable et permettant des
dispositifs oui s'adaptant à la
situation particulière de la martinique
de notre région géographique plus
largement si et guyane mais voilà
quelque chose que vous soulignez au sein
du csm et de la commission culture et
communication passionne bien évidemment
c'est de voir dans quelle mesure on
pourrait trouver des financements pont
réactivé si vous voulez l'économie on va
en discuter dans un bonheur une deuxième
et dérogations c'est véritablement voir
si l'ensemble des dispositifs
réglementaires et législatifs qui sont
appliquées favorise une structuration
des métiers autrement dit voyez est ce
que la mise en place de mesures
particulières ne pourrait pas par
exemple alléger les charges des
employeurs
voyez mieux identifier les travailleurs
amateurs par rapport aux professionnels
voyez mieux identifier le secteur de la
rémunération
voyez c'est l'ensemble des problèmes qui
devraient nous permettre à terme de
consolider ses métiers et d'offrir des
perspectives durables aux métiers
artistiques
alors on va parler de la petite fenêtre
d'espoir qui s'ouvre là où qui s'en
trouvera en ce début de l'année 2000 21
mai après le constat que que vous avez
fait donc les conséquences un grave que
que vous avez souligné à travers cette
ce communiqué cette motion de soutien
aux professionnels de la culture en
martinique
donc vous rappeler qu'il ya une
précarisation des professionnels des
arts et de la culture ralentissement
voire dans certaines périodes arrêt
total de la création artistique etc et
vous fait un certain nombre de
recommandations d'une effet en force de
proposition mais avant c'est le nerf de
la guerre
vous demandez la généralisation des
procédures de soutien financier et
l'application immédiate alors c'était
enfin 2020 ben on va voir maintenant
l'an 2000 21 je sais pas si vous avez
été entendu de ce point de vue là mais
donc généralisation des soutiens
financiers application immédiate à
l'ensemble des professionnels identifié
du secteur c'est ce que fait ça voilà
mais d'abord c'est ça je veux dire c'est
parce que c'est le portefeuille d d une
louise un exode qui a bien et moins
durement touchée j'aimerais aussi
étendre sa aux entreprises artistiques
savez des entreprises sonorisation des
entrevues 2-1 et et qui travaille dans
le il est important que ces ces
entreprises et droit est au dispositif
réglementaire qui sont prévues alors
concernant les professionnels de la
musique par exemple on a vu qu'il ya des
dispositifs qui ont été mises en place
autant par la collectivité de rials par
l'état par la sacem
mais que parfois les gens ont du mal à y
accéder
parce que les statuts si vous voulez y
en a pas qui sont intermittents il y en
a qui se sont pas déclarés
donc effectivement cette situation nous
interpelle et nous amène bien évidemment
à essayer dans ce qu'il faisait - ce de
critères finalement sélectif qui ferait
sortir un petit peu de dudu du processus
du c'est ça c'est une idée en tout cas
c'est une idée parce qu'on me disait
c'est écrit c'est l'habillage de
personnes oui abstraite voilà on sait
bien que parfois il ya des dispositifs
qui sont un peu freinant longues griffes
il était important d'avoir une
flexibilité mais en même temps il est
important aussi que nous profitions de
ce moment là pour que les artistes qui
sont des gens de rémunérer stabilisent
leur situation
alors vous souhaitez aussi vous
recommander la mise en oeuvre d'une
étude prospective 1 permettant de cerner
avec précision les problématiques du
secteur et les solutions permettant donc
de mettre en place un système spécifique
là on y revient encore pour les
intervenants ici des arts et de la
culture et puis vous et là on en arrive
donc à 2021
vous préconisez également de alors je
sais pas qui vous adressez certainement
la ctm al adaoui d'agglomération des
élus des pouvoirs pouvoirs publics quoi
vous occuper la commande aussi bien
publiques que privées devront tous
genres auprès des artistes durant
l'année budgétaire 2020 t1 tout à fait
absolument
alors là si vous voulez ça peut se
matérialiser de plusieurs manières alors
des oeuvres de commande aujourd'hui
effectivement ça concerne la peinture ça
concerne aussi des ihm de nîmes pour une
commune
voyez c'est ça concerne des concours de
composition dont il faut activer tous
voilà bon mais aussi il faut à mon avis
trouver des stratégies nouvelles pour
faire en sorte que par exemple on a bien
vu il n'ya pas très longtemps en
télévision pour tai chi ou la musique
dans les ehpad avec un violoncelliste et
on disait effectivement les bienfaits
donc il est intéressant d'intégrer des
artistes de provisionnel dans les ehpad
dans un certain nombre de dispositifs
collectifs de manière à favoriser voile
et voilà il est également important
d'avoir une planification comme on l'a
fait avec le cnt
pendant les vacances dans les nippes ce
que nous avons fait partie en musique à
mantes nick gens ont fait 49 prestation
en embauchant 140 artistes renouveler
l'opération positif et dit pourrait être
envisagé une action de mise en relation
des commanditaires et des prestataires
tout à fait pour relancer un peu la
machine de type job dating culturel ou
un salon forum de la production
artistique tout à faire alors il y à
tout ça il y a effectivement cessé sa
langue que nous pouvons réaliser autour
de la production artistique faire en
sorte aussi que l'intégration de la
l'offre culturelle dans le tourisme ne
soit pas quelque chose d'à côté mais qui
soit vraiment dynamique que tant dans la
danse tant dans la peinture dans la
littérature tant dans le théâtre et tant
dans la musique
donc je crois que tout ça ce sont des
pistes que nous devons approfondir et
puis y'a aussi l'exportation vous savez
nous avons des hantises et là dessus
d'ailleurs je pense comme ça de gori
privé qui a pas très longtemps qui fait
des concerts dans pas mal de l'ue a
banni
je pense à mario canonge pense à tous
les gens sont gentils plissa s'étendent
en musique bien sûr proposer un plan
daide véritable dites-vous un véritable
plan daide à l'export des oeuvres et des
artistes pour compenser les restrictions
le gage à les écouter j des réflexions
stratégiques
la mise en place des deux projets
l'élaboration de dispositifs nouveaux
mise en place de financements qui nous
permettront si vous voulez d'activer les
ans dans notre pays et de faire en sorte
que on arrête de dire on a beaucoup
d'anti smellit faux bond et qu'on est
des antilles ce qu'ils soient en mesure
de travailler ça qui est important
donc je pense que cette situation est
opportune pour pouvoir réactiver tous là
vous êtes plutôt optimiste vous avez de
l'optimisme pour cette année 2021 c'est
indispensable c'est indispensable
dernier mot la commission culture et
communication du csm et le csm lui même
va continuer cette année à suivre et à
soutenir cet artiste nous en deux ans
d'être à jeun nous avons encore quelques
secondes avant un plan de travail
effectivement nous activerons les
réflexions afin que les paroles et les
partenaires de pour arriver à ce chiffre
est vous pour pour en faire le suivi et
et restituer l'information près de nos
auditrices et auditeurs à qui on
souhaite une bonne journée
voilà merci bien